disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
disco starter set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below
so part of me wishes i had something
positive and inspiring to start with on
what could be such a beautiful holiday
week here in the united states
thanksgiving coming up later this week
unfortunately i don't i have something
potentially very negative but one of the
things that i've always said i want to
do on this program is i don't want to go
overboard
with hyperbole about something being bad
uh but i also don't want to understate
when something is potentially not
looking good let's accurately evaluate
how 2022 and subsequently 2024 is
looking for democrats and for the left
to the extent that the left is
uh
functioning or operating within the
democratic party at this time
and unfortunately democrats are facing a
historic disastrous defeat in 2022 above
and beyond even
what is typical
in the first midterm after a different
party has grabbed the white house our
friend of multiple time former guest on
the show political scientist rachel
bittikoffer is sort of sounding the
alarm on this and saying listen it it
doesn't have to be that bad for
democrats in 2022
but democrats need a plan which is
currently completely lacking so we're
going to talk about that
but at this point i'm comfortable
telling you
that if we accurately evaluate
all of the factors at our disposal right
now
2022 could be a complete and total
disaster for democrats the likes of
which democrats don't recover from
for multiple election cycles and then we
add to that as we mentioned last week
that aside from flipping seats
fighting races
on redistricting alone
democrats could lose a handful of seats
in the house of representatives so i
encourage people to kind of just set the
stage for this
read the article by chauncey de vega in
salon which we're linking to on youtube
by rachel bittikoffer
about what 2022 could be looking like um
rachel bittikoffer
is very very scared uh about what's
going on and chauncey accurately kind of
gives us a number of the important
points here of course with the
november election results of a couple of
weeks ago as one data point the reality
that democrats don't really seem to have
a strategy right now other than to
continue running on we're not trump and
of course trump is gone and that did not
work very well in virginia
um and there's a great conversation with
rachel bittikoffer here
where she is asked what are the errors
being made by democrats and she says
first understand the following about the
outcome in virginia a year before
basically on the night of the 2020
election when it was clear biden had won
the enthusiasm advantage for republicans
was predictable republicans were going
to be out of power which meant they were
going to get enthusiastic and engaged
and they are as stupid as this whole
let's go brandon thing is
it's it's working as an engagement
rallying cry for the sort of dumb dumb
right as we might call it
rachel goes on to say democrats were
going to be in power which meant
democratic voters were going to tune out
and participate less that seems to be
happening
where that vote was going to disappear
was always predictable the democratic
coalition ebbs and flows in terms of
turnout
some of those voters are going to be
democrats others independents who tend
to vote democrats certain demographics
where this ends to happen
tends to happen in terms of turnout such
as younger voters and minorities the
democrats know where they need to focus
you build an infrastructure around the
weakest parts of the coalition not from
the top down but the bottom up even with
all of this knowledge ahead of time the
democrats are not running elections
using that information or redesigning
how redesigning how they run election
campaigns to build on the realities of
the electorate and the impact of
polarization and hyper partisanship
meanwhile
republicans are running a fine-tuned
machine right now
watching the democrats in terry
mcauliffe's team was basically like
watching somebody perform algebra
without having multiplication as a skill
set it's not about just saying hey
junkin is like trump it's about making
an association junkin is like trump
trump is the republican party the
republican party is trump this matters
to you why because it's going to impact
you negatively this is a key part what
the republicans did with critical race
theory was package it through the
emotion about parental control over
education they used it as a proxy it's
not really about critical race theory
because remember critical race theory is
not even being taught in virginia
it's a stand-in for a challenge in white
privilege and whether white parents want
their kids to feel guilty for being
white
it doesn't matter if a random republican
can define what crt is remember they
can't
he knows what it means
the republicans knew what that man would
know when they used the language
critical race theory means we're going
to protect you from having to feel
guilty about being white and for your
kids having to feel guilty for being
white for having your white hegemonic
power challenged in this more diverse
america now there's other stuff in this
article about are democrats bad at
politics not really our subject for
discussion here
i don't believe this is hyperbolic from
rachel bittikoffer and
i also think this is such a unique
situation
with such a huge potential for disaster
that the risk is asymmetrical
and so the strategy has to be
asymmetrical as well what do i mean by
that um some of you who have had like
basic stats know about expected value
right um if i tell you flip a coin
and if it's heads you get nothing and if
it's tails you get a hundred dollars
mathematically the expected value of
that flip is fifty dollars but there's
no outcome where you actually get fifty
dollars you they get zero or a hundred
but statistically you have an expected
value of fifty dollars um if you have a
ten-sided die that you roll
and the outcomes are if you roll a one
you get a dollar if you wrote a
roll of four you get four dollars right
the expected value for the average roll
is five even though the reality is you
might get one you might get ten now with
this 2022 2024 stuff
even if the outcome of total
blowout disaster for democrats is only
10
it would be so disastrous
that you need to go above and beyond the
expected value thought process when you
look at it and you say well i should
assign as much effort to preventing the
one out of ten scenario or the one out
of twenty scenario
uh based on its mathematical likelihood
you're understating how disastrous it
would be it would be such a disaster for
republicans to do as well as rachel
points out that you actually need to
over prepare for it because the risk is
asymmetric uh or asymmetrical and i
think
rachel bittikoffer is rightly sounding
the alarm on that uh we're gonna delve
much deeper early in 22
into senate house and governorships but
those who were understating and saying
well you know
new jersey governorship was no big deal
because oftentimes democrats just
straight up lose and phil murphy won
even if by a little bit so that's not
that bad and it's not looking that bad
in the house
there's a scenario that's coming
together which is maybe not the
predominant scenario but it's a
plausible scenario that is potentially a
10-year disaster for democrats and for
the left in the united states and i
think it's a good thing that people like
rachel bittikoffer are sounding the
alarm on it
over the weekend we started to see
not only the protests as a result of the
full not guilty verdicts for kyle
rittenhouse in kenosha wisconsin
we also started to see
covered protests turned violent around
the world now you might say david what
are people protesting the virus no no
what i mean is protests around covet
guidelines many countries starting to
put in place
stricter guidelines for the unvaccinated
as cases are spiking dramatically in
many countries in europe including
germany austria and others and the
protests against guidelines against
vaccine requirements are turning
increasingly violent i'm going to give
you a little bit of a tour
through some of these dutch police
police arrest 7 amid unrest in the hague
police arrested seven rioters in the
hague after youths set fire in the
streets and threw fireworks at officers
the unrest came a day after police
opened fire on protesters in rotterdam
amidst violence that broke out at a
protest against coronavirus restrictions
um
that's in the hague
the rioting in the hague was on a
smaller scale than the pitched battles
on the streets of rotterdam where police
say three rioters were hit by bullets
and investigations are underway to
figure out if they were shot by police
in austria italy and croatia protests
erupt over virus rules
tens of thousands of protesters many
from far-right groups marched through
vienna austria on saturday after this
nationwide lockdown was announced
austrian lockdown starts today comes as
average daily deaths have tripled
hospitals and heavily hit states are
reaching capacity lockdown will be at
least 10 days could be 20.
um
discontinuing in so many different parts
of the world in italy 3 000 turned out
in the capital circus maximus where
ancient time in ancient times romans
would have popular entertainment to
protest green pass certificates required
to go to workplaces restaurants cinemas
theater sports venues and gyms and long
distance train bus and ferry travel in
northern ireland people opposed to
vaccine passports protest protested
outside the city hall in belfast
some protesters carried signs that have
been widely criticized as offensive
comparing coronavirus restrictions to
the actions of nazi germany in croatia
thousands have gathered in france there
have been violent protesters uh i'm
sorry in france they have been
condemning violent protester protests in
the caribbean island of guadalupe one of
france's overseas territories where cars
have been set on fire
tens of thousands protest belgium's
tighter coveted 19 rules you see
police fire hoses brought out to try to
quell protests tens of thousands
demonstrating there
marcher marchers came to protest the
government's strong advice to get
vaccinated and any possible moves to
impose mandatory shots shouting freedom
freedom freedom and singing the
anti-fascist song bella chao
protesters lined up behind a banner that
says together for freedom
dutch police arrest more than 30
amid ongoing unrest already looked at
one article of that they are describing
an orgy of violence
interesting language
and france has sent special forces to
the caribbean region of guadalupe over
covid riots
what is the end game here
because it is increasingly looking
like there are going to be
ebbs and flows of covid
for at least a couple more years
now there is the hope
based on israeli data
that the third dose
creates more lasting immunity than the
initial set or regimen
of two doses and of course if that's the
case
if people get uh vaccinated
we may see a more permanent decline in
covered rates and particularly
hospitalizations and deaths but at this
point it's pretty clear based on the
level of interest in getting vaccinated
in a variety of countries which is too
low
that at least for a couple of years
while we hopefully wait as vincent
racaniello told us may happen for a
decline in the severity of covid
as we wait for that that there is going
to be
a very long period of time of the ebbs
and flows so
what do we do
do we learn to sort of live with it
do we say well you've gotta just
continue with a sort of
semi-restricted way of life for a couple
of years
do you go to let it rip at a certain
point as many have suggested saying well
one once the vaccines are widely
available for everyone it becomes
personal responsibility there's problems
with that i don't have the answer but
what's increasingly clear is number one
to the extent that there are guidelines
there are going to be people protesting
and hopefully not but worryingly in
increasingly violent fashion number one
and number two
this is not going away anytime soon and
so i don't know the answer we're going
to be doing an interview next week i
think it is related to the kind of
bigger picture at this point in time but
i'm curious to hear from you what should
happen given that this is likely to be
the case for years and i know people who
are saying i don't know that i'm ever
going to a restaurant again okay that's
certainly one approach
but self-selecting out of life has its
own problems not to quote donald trump
but over the long term obviously that's
going to create a problem as well what
should be done at this point let me know
your thoughts you can find me on twitter
at deepakman and we'll have a continuing
conversation about this
one of our sponsors is disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day the disco starter set
is a simple way to take care of your
skin in three quick steps the face
cleanser stick fights oily skin the
exfoliating face scrub prevents razor
burn and the face moisturizer keeps your
skin hydrated disco can also help with
ingrown hairs dry skin acne and other
things you just need 60 seconds a day
i've been using it for a while now i'm
seeing a noticeable difference maybe you
can even tell
check out disco try out the products for
yourself you will like the results and
you'll get 30 off when you go to let's
disco.com pacman or just enter the code
pacman the link is down below
so we are going to be doing another one
of our great viewer town halls this next
one has been scheduled for uh december
14th we're gonna do it at 6 00 p.m
eastern time it will be streaming live
on the second youtube channel the pacman
live youtube channel which you can find
at youtube.compacmanlive
i think we took something like 60 or 70
different calls from viewers on the last
one
and of course members will get priority
during the town hall you can sign up at
joinpackman.com i encourage you to do so
all right this this is really beyond
belief
um donald trump has written a book
written is not actually the right word
and it is literally a picture book
you know all those jokes about trump's
executive orders are written in crayon
trump's presidential library would be
pictures of tweets
um and then like the not jokes like for
example trump's presidential daily
briefing was a single page double spaced
mostly pictures and charts that was true
trump has done what many former
presidents do which is he made a book
not wrote a book made a book
but it is a literal picture book
with pictures
and descriptions of the pictures written
apparently by trump which read like his
old tweets you you just have to see this
um donald trump jr tweeting about it
excited saying huge news
a new book by president donald trump is
being published coming out next month
our journey together
a beautiful 300 plus page color coffee
table style
read all about it guys it's it's a
picture book um the washington examiner
writes about it
and
it they include some
pictures
from the book i guess you would say and
like for example i'm describing this to
our audio audience there's a picture of
trump sitting in the oval office with
nancy pelosi
and the caption which i get it's really
the writing it says attempting to listen
to crazy nancy pelosi in the oval office
such natural disagreement
many presidents write books trump has
done a picture book
with captions that are insults of people
another picture this is the picture that
we now know was a staged picture
from the white house i believe it's the
situation room we know that this picture
was staged
and it says the night we got abu bakr
al-baghdadi
we destroyed isis under my watch
now terrorists are back in the middle
east so this one's in it this picture is
an insult of joe biden we we since
learned this picture was staged trump
was actually i believe playing golf at
the relevant time
um
one more example trump sitting alongside
german chancellor angela merkel and then
british prime minister theresa may
and the the caption is an insult to
theresa may where trump wrote meeting
with german chancellor and british prime
minister theresa tried hard
but didn't get the job done
boris johnson is much better
for the united kingdom
and then just like kind of family
pictures of different kinds
you you really couldn't write this stuff
guys i mean this is
it's
we talk about trump being
sort of semi-literate in the sense that
we know he hasn't read a book
in decades at least maybe in his entire
adult life
we know that his writing was very
strange and compromised and so even in
doing
what just about every president does
writing a book it's a picture book
with the equivalent of his tweets
insulting people and of course to sell
it they say it's a coffee table style
book what would it it's a picture book
guys it's absolutely insane
and even more
maybe pathetic
is that this picture book got trump an
interview on fox news which is what i
want to talk about next
so donald trump was interviewed about
his book if you can believe it the
interviewer is fox news's mark levin
the main question should be sir why is
this a picture book most presidents
write a real book
why did you decide to do a picture book
now the reality is if trump wrote a book
it would be very obvious he didn't write
it because trump can't write in any way
that would lead to a book trump's
previous books were written by ghost
writers tony schwartz was one of those
ghost writers he's talked about how
trump doesn't read trump doesn't write
it's all a humiliating pathetic thing
okay so trump's interviewed about the
book
the entire interview is a humiliating
farce this is an interview that even for
trump even for trump
is particularly riddled with lies so
trump opens the interview
with multiple lies about gas prices
let's start there see make it a game see
if you can count the number of lies we
weren't leaving 85 billion dollars
behind we weren't leaving 10 cents
behind i said every bolt every screw
every nail
comes out
and all of these things it was a
beautiful period i was under assault
like no president has ever been i and
sorry this is not even actually the
right clip let's start with the gas
price clip i apologize
uh
gasoline was 1.87
that was a year ago
and now it's i guess just hit
and fifty cents in california the rest
to follow and i predicted this okay so
let let go through that line by let's
look at everything trump said trump says
he predicted this listen everyone
predicted that when demand
goes back up as the pandemic eases gas
prices will go up everybody predicted it
that's not unique number two trump says
a year ago gas was 1.87 that's a lie
a year ago the national average for
gasoline was 220. now you could say well
it was still lower than now yeah but it
wasn't 187 it was 220. and then trump
says gas is 750 in california now is it
possible that there is a gas station in
california selling super premium for 750
it's possible
the gas price in california officially
right now is 338. you don't compare
187 or actually 220
to what you can find for super premium
at one gas station we compare
actual official numbers california gas
is 338
a year ago it was 220 nationally
we have to compare to official numbers
um i'm sorry california is at 470
uh and that's the number that we it's
not 750. it's 470. the official price
now nationally is 338. um and this is
called cherry-picking of data it's lies
all the way down he's lying about
everything uh okay then trump talking
about how great a period it was when he
was president just everybody was happy
russia was happy everybody was happy
assume i don't think any president has
ever been under assault like this
and one thing after another phony
impeachments
uh i call it the impeachment hoax number
one the impeachment hoax number two the
the mueller
thing although it worked out good but it
took two and a half years and it made it
very difficult to deal with
remember trump still falsely claims that
the mueller report exonerated him on
obstruction of justice which it didn't
do it's like ancient history at this
point but just he's still lying about it
in countries in particular russia you
know we could have done some great
things with russia
very good for our country for our
country also good for russia right but
you couldn't do that because they would
have said oh he loves russia
these people are sick
[Laughter]
so trump continuing to kind of rewrite
history sort of in the same way he also
and this is one of my favorite things
trump talks about how much he and north
korean dictator kim jong-un liked each
other remember this infamous rally
speech where trump said
he wrote me beautiful letters and then
we fell in love
um trump going back and telling his
stories about kim jong-un during this
very strange interview ended up in a war
that's the biggest problem we had
so i became
you know
we did very well with kim jong-un
and we liked each other now remember we
liked each other okay i mean we know
trump is sort of smitten by dictators we
didn't really do well with kim jong-un
in the sense that kim jong-un made the
same
vague
promises to trump
that north korean dictators have been
making to global leaders for a very long
time
they didn't do any of the stuff and in
fact remember that trump just walked
away from the second meeting because it
was going nowhere predictably
so trump didn't really do anything with
kim jong-un a terrible thing to say we
like to i'll get criticized oh he likes
kim jong-un well
that's what we have and i did i got
along with him great he got along with
me great after a very rough start
if you remember little rocket man
and the buttons he said we have a red
button and we'll use it i said no our
button is bigger than yours and our
button works and it was nasty and then
all of a sudden
it ended and and all of that stuff
and what's funny is it ended in
kim jong-un didn't do any of the stuff
he promised to do and trump just stopped
talking about it it's actually very
funny trump wants you to believe it
ended in some kind of geopolitical
success it ended where trump just bailed
on the second summit
north korea didn't stick to any of the
promises and it was never mentioned
again as a foreign policy goal okay then
trump going back to the lies about the
1918 flu which he still calls the 1917
flu and is still confused about all over
the world
so in 1917 as you know we had the
spanish flu it was called
and it possibly killed as many as a
hundred million people you know i don't
know if you read the history of the
spanish flu but you probably i think you
read about everything
but but
it probably was a thing that was most
responsible for ending world war one
because all the soldiers were sick
and many were dying
the spanish flu was devastating and they
say up to 100 million people died
and it probably did end world war one
but a hundred million people
okay
um again
you can't even keep up with the lies it
was the 1918 flu not 1917. we've looked
up and down we interviewed a world war
a spanish flu historian
and said uh who told us there's there's
no reason at all anyone would call it
the 1917 flu number one number two it
did not end world war one that is not
true trump keeps repeating it it is not
true now trump says it might have killed
100 million people um the the consensus
death toll for the
spanish flu
is considered 17 to 50 million and
there's a sort of it could be as high as
100 million because we don't have great
data from some other countries but the
important thing is trump's trying to use
it to minimize covid in the u.s
the spanish flu death toll is believed
to be 675 000.
we now have almost eight hundred
thousand deaths from covet
so covid is already more deadly in the
us than the 1918 flu pandemic it's all
lies
all the time do you think that the
average fox viewer
realizes the number of lies that are
being told here i think the answer is no
uh trump then pulls out the communism
talking points number one i love our
country and our country is based on the
constitution and you know our country is
not living up to the constitution right
now with the kind of things you see it's
uh
they're trying to subvert it now
importantly
when this is if mark levin was an actual
interviewer
uh he would have said sir why is your
book a picture book okay i already
mentioned that he would have said why do
you keep calling it the 1917 flu nobody
says that that's the right name for it
it's the 1918 flu
uh why are you lying about gas prices
that's not true but when the
constitution stuff comes up a real
interviewer would say
exactly which aspect of the constitution
or bill of rights are they subverting
and who is they tell me exactly it's not
asked and mark levin who claims to be an
expert on the constitution just allows
it to hop to happen
and more so now than anybody would ever
believe
bernie sanders is saying i can't believe
they're doing this this is far more than
what they're doing to our country
is perhaps you know they talk socialism
this is communism and so now it's not
communism there's no communism here
there's there's been no
government takeover
of businesses and they're they're i mean
there's just not communism here so many
ways
uh there's no freedom of the press the
press is totally corrupt the press and
them are the same there's no freedom of
the press that's how communism starts
now those are literally all lies and
mark levin does nothing to push back
against it
trump then tries to say he did a really
great job on covid really really good
job
but i built him a hospital i sent in the
hospital ship i built hospitals in
louisiana i built hospitals all over
all over
portable hospitals thousands of beds we
did a phenomenal job
except when it came to public relations
because no matter what we did the press
would not cover it fairly so we did a
fantastic job yeah
we now know that thanks to trump's uh
inaction and delayed response
and for months not talking about masks
and saying 15 cases would soon go to
zero
those decisions people were going to die
people were going to die there's no
doubt about it but
tens of thousands of needless deaths
simply from trump's uh slow action okay
wrapping this up trump actually talking
about the book and he talks about you
know his picture book it's just
humiliating
yeah at a meeting filled with
individuals
what was that all about
well i have a number of pictures and i
have a picture of nancy pelosi i have a
picture of uh
of uh merkel everybody guys
this is the most childish thing most
presidents write a book trump is talking
about pictures that he put in the book i
got along with very well that was a
pointer also we have a lot of pointers
you know there are a lot of people
pointing
but with pelosi
okay so there it is and then lastly
lastly here is trump saying something
unintelligible about gasoline once again
i don't think people see it that way
they knew that they got gasoline for x
dollars a tank
and now they can multiply it times four
and they're saying what's happened okay
and of course gasoline prices have not
multiplied themselves by four and trump
telling lie after lie so the missing
question really is why did you write a
picture book most presidents choose to
write uh
actual you know they they write uh you
chose a picture book that's interesting
sir tell tell us why that question not
asked and a completely bizarre
humiliating interview with the former
president we're going to take a quick
break make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show and we'll
have much more coming up
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
all right this is super interesting you
guys may remember we've been covering
this incredible double standard this
incredible hypocrisy where fox news
hosts and many in right-wing media have
been slamming the joe biden
vaccine mandate protocol requirement in
which
large employers with more than 100
employees have to either
get their employees vaccinated
get proof that their employees are
vaccinated or they have to test their
unvaccinated employees once a week now
fox news has implemented a much stricter
protocol where you either need to be
vaccinated or tested daily and you're
required to wear a mask when working on
location in certain areas so the fox
protocol the fox requirement the fox
guidelines call it whatever you want it
is stricter stricter than the ones
outlined by joe biden um another fox
host was confronted about this this is
really interesting this is pete hegseth
who's a big anti-biden guy big bomb
thrower and he was interviewed by
mediaite's editor-in-chief aidan
mclaughlin and when he was confronted
with this double standard
where hegseth is regularly railing on
the biden protocol but fox says his
employer's protocol is stricter he
first wasn't really sure what to say
then he resorted to attacking mediaite
which might not surprise you let's take
a look at this very instructive
there was a vaccine or test requirement
at the patriot awards which is very
similar to the policy at fox news do you
have an issue with fox news having a
policy like that which is effectively
the same as biden's vaccine mandate for
big businesses
uh i uh
you know you're not mandated to get the
vaccine because you can get a test right
now remember
it's the same thing with joe biden
you're not mandated to get the vaccine
because you can get a test
i'm not in charge of it
i don't make the calls but
either you
you have the option to get a test so
you're not it's not actually a complete
vaccine mandate and that's fine i mean
it's uh it's not my call so i'm grateful
for the people that provide us this
opportunity and
and um the show went off without a hitch
right but it's just that you know joe
biden's vaccine mandate for big
businesses has been the subject of
criticism and that's even less stringent
than the one at fox news right it
requires weekly testing as opposed to
daily testing so i'm curious as to why
you have an issue with the joe biden
vaccine mandate right but no problem
with the one at fox news beautiful
what do you want me to say
well
answer the question say for example well
uh
i'm doing it to get clicks
or it's our editorial position and it's
totally hypocritical or like what he
wants you to say is answer the question
pete
i mean
ultimately uh
companies have prerogatives what the
government shouldn't be doing is telling
them what to do
the government shouldn't be telling them
what to do
every company has its own policies and i
am beyond grateful for the opportunity
to work at the fox news channel and it
does things
that no other organization does
including your organization media so now
he just goes into attacking the the
interviewer it's part of the trash heap
of left-wing media
that does the same thing everyone else
does that's why we're number one i mean
i i can't even imagine what the clicks
are on your site is it like 15 people a
day like only journalists in new york
city they click on your that 16 good
they're the only people that read media
actually people read read the fox news
channel so you guys want to nitpick and
do your thing it's cool but it's funny
to say it's nitpicking to point out that
fox news has been waging a propaganda
war against biden's vaccine mandate
while having a stricter mandate for its
own employees pete hegseth calls that
nitpicking
i i could not be more grateful for the
fox okay so there it is so he eventually
comes across something that sounds kind
of like an explanation which is hey
listen i'm fine with private companies
doing what they think is best but they
shouldn't be told by the government that
that's what they had to do but in in
getting to that explanation
he first has to attack media to get
there and insult them and say you guys
only get 15 clicks and this is this is
actually very common remember when
tucker carlson was confronted with the
same thing
his reaction was just as bizarre okay so
i i have a question here about fox news
um yeah
you said fox news has no vaccine mandate
but according to newsweek the company
requires unvaccinated employees to
submit to daily covid testing which is
stricter than biden's mandate which
calls for weekly testing for businesses
that employ more than 100 people is fox
news denying the civil liberties uh of
its employees by being stricter than
president biden fair question i don't
know i mean you should probably ask
newsweek it sounds like they got a
pretty precise handle on what's
happening
hey
if it's wrong let me know if i'm wrong
it's
it's completely wrong as i noted the
other night
um i'm not
you know so what is the policy i'm not
going to talk about to speak
for the company
um on this because i don't run the
company and i'm not
you know i'm just now that's very
disingenuous tucker could just speak to
his experience with the policy as an
employee he doesn't have to speak on it
as an employer it's very disingenuous
company um
my personal preference is that fox news
would you know make a statement about
what its policies are but i think like a
lot of companies
um you know they're hesitant to do that
because like why would you even want to
get involved in that conversation here's
the bottom line
you know there are a lot of infectious
diseases out there a lot and
a lot with much higher mortality rates
than covid19
and you know there's hiv
so then as a reminder he goes into kind
of comparing and equating
covid vaccination and covet to hiv which
is of course uh
an insane analogy given that hiv is
sexually transmitted you can't sneeze on
someone and give him hiv there's no
vaccine for hiv i mean
every time that they are actually
confronted with this
it's a fair question every time
they know that they're stuck in an
inconsistent position and they either
get angry and turn to insults or they do
what about ism so nice job there by
mediaites aidan mclaughlin and pete
hegseth looking kind of like a doofus i
must say hey i i want to talk about
you know sometimes we
sometimes uh uh we focus on the wrong
thing and we miss the forest for the
trees
when we talk about a story it can happen
to any of us
and um
there was an incredible series of videos
from new york city in which
hundreds of proud boys this right-wing
group
committed a crime an infraction we can
call it
for which
black teens in new york city for lack of
a better term and i saw it have you know
but when i was on the subway all the
time pre-pandemic i would see it all the
time
um
black teens will often get arrested by
nypd for doing something that hundreds
of proud boys did over the weekend which
is they jumped the turnstiles they went
in through an exit door on the subway
and
literally nothing happened
i'm going to play this video here for
our video audience and you see
that there are just
dozens and dozens and multiple videos of
these proud boys
on the new york subway
and someone says it's open
and then you start to see these guys
pour in through what is supposed to be
an exit door this is called jumping turn
styles they're not always literally
jumping turn styles very often it was
like as i was leaving i would push open
the exit
and people would slip in
and you see them here
now
civil rights attorney and long-time
public defender scott heckinger tweeted
about this and said
as a public defender i represented
literally hundreds of black men and
women accused of doing this most
literally couldn't afford 2.75 subway
fare the difference between eating and
not eating for them arrested caged
forced to plea to the crime of theft of
services
but when you're white and proud
right um these proud boys at least in
these videos exclusively white so is it
only a racial issue no but there's a big
racialized component to this and the
turn style jumping used as a
justification to detain young black men
on the new york subway is a story almost
as old as the subway itself for a
comparison we do have video of how new
york city police
deal with some of these other folks and
we have video we're showing here
where you see a group of police officers
they are determined to find the
turnstile jumpers
and
as we follow the camera you see multiple
officers get on a subway car
and they start they actually pull out
tasers in this case
and they're pushing around
one guy
believed to have been turn style jumping
and it's it's really depressing and uh
one two three four five six seven eight
officers
and a scuffle begins anyway you guys
know the story you guys know the story
so this is just another one of these
cases where we see it and we say what
what is going on here what is the
explanation here
and why are there just dozens and dozens
of proud boys pouring in the exit door
jumping turnstiles and everything's
very very calm you tell me if there's a
different explanation i'm glad to see it
but this is a classic
classic that i witnessed 10 times i
guess
dozen or so times when i was on the
subway all the time before the pandemic
just haven't really been using public
transit since the start of the pandemic
um but something very much uh to think
about interesting just little tidbit
from the proud boy protests over the
weekend let's take a quick break i do
want to talk about ron desantis after
this short break and a bunch of other
things glad you're with me today on this
shortened thanksgiving week
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show there's a really
interesting new report from cnn's gabby
orr and steve contorno about donald
trump's growing fury quite frankly that
florida republican governor ron desantis
known to summon the pandemic era as ron
death santis you may remember that
trump's furious that desantis is
increasingly popular and increasingly
being talked about as an alternative to
donald trump for 2022. now you might
recall
that back in july at cpac they did a
straw poll they do these at all c-packs
and donald trump easily won that 2024
straw poll he uh trump had 70 of the
vote the other the only other notable
participant was ron desantis with 21
percent of that straw poll vote
and throughout the pandemic when trump
was president and ron desantis ignored
every coveted guideline opened the state
i think it was to wwe wrestling and ufc
fights very early
later desantis said cruise ships if you
want to leave from florida you can't
require vaccines
trump loved it trump was all about ron
desantis and trumpists were all about
ron desantis he's great he's the best
how terrific pro business he's been
doing great things okay
but now
as ron desantis has become more popular
and is being seen increasingly almost
like a more competent version of donald
trump all of trump's terrible ideas but
more competence to actually get them
done
trump is apparently furious and desantis
also seems to be realizing hey
i might be up against trump in 2024 i
need to start distancing as well let's
take a look at the cnn report about this
and it is very very interesting which
says people close to both men first
noticed the palpable shift in trump's
posture towards desantis earlier this
year as enthusiasm for the florida
governor swelled
among donors and republican operatives
who praised his laissez-faire response
to the coveted pandemic
the more desantis popularity soared the
more obsessed trump became with
receiving credit for his political
celebrity
in april trump told fox news desantis
would certainly be under consideration
for vp if he were to launch a campaign
in 2024 by 20 by october trump was
demanding he publicly rule out a white
house bid of his own so as recently as
last month trump was saying
desantis needs to come out and say i
won't run and of course desantis hasn't
done that because desantis might well be
thinking of running
it's not that trump is complaining about
ron but he likes ron to he likes to
remind ron and others that he made him
said a person close to trump who added
trump has been telling people around him
that desantis could show more gratitude
a statement to cnn from trump spokesman
taylor budowicz appeared to confirm
trump's obsession with receiving credit
for desantis's success buddhic said the
former president's 2020 victory in
florida paved the way for republicans
including ron desantis to sweep in 2022
and suggested trump catapulted desantis
into the governor's mansion with his
endorsement
though the two remain in regular contact
trump is increasingly irritated at
desantis's refusal to publicly dismiss a
2024 bid of his own if the former
president decides to run two people
close to the situation said desantis has
privately assured trump he has no
intention of challenging him but they
noted trump won't be fully satisfied
until he says so publicly
um
though desantis previously dismissed
2024 chatter is nonsense he has avoided
taking the unequivocal public bow
vowed not to challenge trump he has
filed to run for re-election in 2022.
the best case scenario for the left
is that trump goes full metal jacket
against ron desantis desantis then
retaliates and it becomes a huge
nightmare and it helps republicans and
pro implode now i am the first to admit
the country is in serious trouble
when a governor with the deaths of
thousands tens of thousands of innocent
americans from covid
uh on his hands
is seeing his popularity take off that
bodes really poorly for the united
states of america but you just saw 70
million people
vote for a doofus imbecile
who killed hundreds of thousands with
his sheer incompetence in mishandling
the pandemic so we've been in serious
trouble for a while now they seem to
want to some degree
something like desantis there's a very
different direction that the republican
electorate could be going which is to
say we need a different type of
republican we need like mitt romney we
need liz cheney who by the way liz
cheney voted more than 90 percent of the
time with trump's position so it's not
like liz cheney is some big victory
right but it would be different for
republicans to say the trump thing
didn't work and we're not going to keep
going with it they seem to want
a crazy trump-like figure that would be
more able to do the things that donald
trump wanted to do but wasn't able to do
and unfortunately that very well could
be ron desantis
very very scary stuff
because the left is so poorly positioned
going into 22 like we talked about at
the top of the show
we're kind of relegated to this very
lame position
of having to hope that they fight
against themselves and desantis versus
trump could be a really great thing
we had another insane weekend
of the conspiracy mind virus that is
plaguing the american right wing it's
conspiracies everywhere you look let's
take a little tour through it on the
maria bartoromo program yesterday
morning on fox
marsha blackburn showed up senator
marsha blackburn
and claimed that joe biden is about to
replace kamala harris
which the president can't actually do
but
senator marsha blackburn doesn't seem to
care and of course maria bartoromo now
loves conspiracy theories
senator is there anything you want to
say about kamala harris she was given
the role of acting by the way why is
there music and why does maria bartoromo
have to yell over the music just a tip
production question when joe biden got
his colonoscopy last week colin
yeah
and i i think when you look at what
she has done she has failed at every
task that she's been given that's why
there are many in the white house who
are so frustrated with her it's going to
be interesting to see interesting to see
who they push forward to take her place
what
uh and you know some people in the
comments said oh she's referring to in
biden's re-election in 2024 that's not
what they mean many of them don't even
believe biden's running for reelection
so she's talking about who are they
going to replace kamala with
then we go to something really bizarre
steve bannon appearing on
some kind of very strange it appears to
be a chinese propaganda show it's not
even clear what this is
and pushing vaccine conspiracies about
segregation and very very strange stuff
of religion and so i think that this is
very powerful you see every day with the
new federal state remember the new
federal state's only a year and a half
old it's only 18 months old and look
look look is what's happened today we're
commemorating the third anniversary of
really the rule of law of the of the
great presentation we had that day at
the pierre hotel and look how much power
uh that the rule of law foundation rule
of law society the whistleblower
movement you've changed history right
here today you can hear the protest in
this city and the protest is about
anti-vaccine right and it's not that
people are anti-vaxxed is that their
vaccine hesitant right
and the reason they're vaccine hesitant
is that the information hasn't been put
out about exactly what happened in the
woolheim lab what is this virus really
about
and why uh therapeutics prophylactic
therapeutics like hydroxychloroquine or
ivermectin or all these other attributes
and what they can do and so the whole
world right now is is questioning
whether it's in europe or in france or
in austria or the united states there's
a big protest here today about about
american citizens who are uh you know
american born right who are protesting
the these overreaching mandates to take
what on earth is bannon talking about
take your freedom away so i think if you
look at the new federal state and what
it's been able to accomplish in 18
months and what the uh whistleblower
movement and what g news and gtv and
particularly the rule of law just in
three years remember it was three years
ago today all right so there's there's
steve bannon uh with um more anti-vaxx
propaganda we also had uh protes a
number of d he's right there were
anti-vaccine protests over the weekend
at one of them
uh the big meme was about
the racism
of vaccine requirements medical
segregation is racist set a sign
stop the mandate before it's too late
this is a new
very often the right will do this
they'll turn something on its head
and so they'll spend a decade saying
the claims of racism from the left are
bogus
the claims of racism from the left are
racist etc they'll do that and then all
of a sudden they'll say hey actually hey
this is racist something that's not
actually racist vaccine requirements now
are racist
then we go to
alex jones uh once again at this
reawaken america tour which seems to be
going on every single weekend
here is alex jones taking a sort of
bizarre kind of rapture revelation end
times approach now with the religious
crowd at this event we are literally
seeing the book of revelations begin to
come true right in front of us and this
is the most important time in human
history since christ walked the earth
yeah so this is actually this is getting
very common a lot of these types that
you don't
always
associate with the religious nuttery we
just associate them with the kind of
like more
uh agnostic conspiracy nuttery they are
going in in the direction of jumping on
board with the religious nuttery um and
then speaking of of which
continuing to see trivialization
um of the holocaust at another one of
these anti-vaxx protests i believe this
one in new york city you see another one
of these yellow stars go by and i'll
play that again for our audience you can
see the yellow star kind of near the
penske truck
which says yellow it's a yellow star
that says unvaccinated on it the
continued trivialization of the
holocaust which is uh just kind of
standard operating procedure at this
point point for people like marjorie
taylor green and others so
every single weekend every single
weekend it is conspiracy after
conspiracy we had the sherry 10 penny
video
of her saying that vaccinating children
is a late term abortion
um and that covet testing is torture and
on and on and on and it is getting
really bad i don't know what turns this
around i really don't
uh but it is extraordinarily disturbing
we have a voicemail number that you can
call anytime you want the number is 2192
david p
here is a voicemail it's sort of
tongue-in-cheek but it gets at a very
good point which is if gas prices are
thanks to biden
and gas prices are up everywhere it's
all thanks to biden right take a listen
to this
good afternoon mr pakman sir i have a
question about gas prices
uh knowing that obviously the gas prices
are
joe biden's fault i see that the gas
prices have also gone up to about five
dollars
u.s uh in canada wow and i'm just trying
to figure out what socialist policies
that uh brandon has implemented into
canada to cause them to have also
a very expensive gas prices even higher
gas prices than we do here
uh
love to hear from you yeah and of course
the caller makes a good point which is
gas prices are up globally
why is it joe biden's fault again and
you guys know me
i do not play these political games with
gas prices whether it's a democratic
president or a republican president and
whether gas prices are up or gas prices
are down go look at my clips from when
gas prices were low and obama was
president i was other than
tongue-in-cheek joking around i was not
praising barack obama for lowering gas
prices american presidents have very
little that they can do
what they can do
is if they want to dip into the
strategic oil reserve it is believed
that they could pull down gas prices by
18 to 20 cents a gallon and it would
take a period of time for that to happen
but of course the caller is right you
look around the world and you see the
same thing how is it joe biden's fault
again republicans love love love
doing the gas price games it's pathetic
but a lot of people fall for it oh we've
got a great bonus show for you today
finally
trump's postmaster general louis de joy
he may be on his way out and we'll tell
you why number two
new york city wants to limit the use of
various artificial intelligence tools
for hiring employees i'll explain and
we now have the results of that estate
tax giveaway that was part of trump's
tax plan back in 2017 that was
implemented in 2018 it dramatically
reduced irs revenue from inheritance it
had the exact effect that the very rich
wanted it to have we have the full
numbers and we'll talk about them on
today's bonus show get access to the
bonus show by signing up at
jointpakman.com remember that on
december 14th 6 pm eastern we'll be
doing the next viewer town hall on the
pacman live youtube channel make sure
you're subscribed to that channel
we will give of course priority to our
website members but everybody will be
allowed to call in everybody everybody
will be allowed to call in so number one
subscribe to the pacman live youtube
channel number two if you want a much
better shot of getting on with me during
our town hall uh sign up at
joinpacman.com you also will get access
to the bonus show as a member and we
will see you there in mere minutes or
right back here on tomorrow's show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the disco
starter set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get thirty percent off at
letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below